eco vide en russie où un seul tiers de
la population est totalement en vacciner
on a une situation sanitaire qui se
dégrade sur place ont fait le point mais
que notre correspondant à moscou antoine
gayraud
bonjour antoine alors les journées se
suivent et se ressemblent mais les
chiffres du coït sont toujours plus loin
vous à dire à nouveau record sur le
front du coc vide en russie celui du
nombre de nouveaux cas quotidiens
ces dernières 24 heures ce samedi ce
chiffre s'élève à 41
1335 le nombre de décès quotidiens lui
aussi reste à un niveau très élevé même
s'il n'atteint pas le record d'hier il
s'élève à 1188 décès constatés l'église
orthodoxe qui occupe une place
importante dans la vie sociale
de nombreux russes s'est également
exprimé sur la situation sanitaire
l'institution préconise un confinement
strict et la généralisation du recours
aux qr code écoutez
nous y arriverons tôt ou tard et le plus
tôt sera le mieux parce que chaque jour
nous perdons un millier de personnes
c'est comme si nous perdions chaque jour
un régiment pendant la guerre vu le taux
de mortalité je pense que l'on peut
parler de catastrophe nationale
le ministre russe de la santé est pour
ça qu est pour sa part actuellement en
déplacement dans les régions afin de se
rendre compte de la situation sur place
il en a profité pour annoncer l'envoi de
nouveaux stocks en province des stocks
de vaccins donc il il s'est inquiétée
également de l'augmentation de
l'incidence du coc vie 19 sur les
enfants écoutez il faut souligner qu'il
est très important de protéger les tout
jeunes enfants parce que l' expertise
d'un nouveau médicament est actuellement
en cours elle est même déjà terminé en
fait on espère qu'il sera disponible
sous peu tous ces vaccins sont produits
sur la base du sérum spoutnik qui a déjà
fait ses preuves quant à sa sûreté et
son efficacité
face à une population réticente à la
vaccination vous l'avez rappelé un peu
plus d'un tiers seulement des russes se
sont fait vacciner les autorités russes
cherchent donc à savoir comment casser
l'élan de cette 4e 20 quatrième vague
pas particulièrement meurtrières elles
espèrent que la semaine chaumet qui
s'achève ce dimanche y contribuera